stop the boats Rishi sunax pledged to
the country easy to say but the Prime
Minister reminded today how hard it is
to deliver the court of appeal ruling
against the government's Rwanda plan
there is a real risk that persons sent
to Rwanda will be returned to their home
countries where they faced persecution
or other inhumane treatment when in fact
they have a good claim for Asylum and
that unless and until the deficiencies
in its Asylum processes are corrected
removal of Asylum Seekers to Rwanda will
be unlawful
government now with another legal fight
on its hands the Home Secretary voicing
her dismay the Prime Minister and I have
made a promise to the British people to
stop the boats we are committed to
delivering on that promise we've got an
unsustainable problem that we need to
fix and whilst of course we are
disappointed with the decision today we
will be putting in an application to
seek permission to appeal maybe even
more than the Prime Minister the Home
Secretary has staked her political
career on stopping the boats Central to
that the goal of getting these flights
off the ground as early as this summer
now that's been blocked by the courts
conservative MPS are getting restless
the opposition and making the most of it
the government's got no plan it's got a
gimmick which is the Rwanda scheme a
gimmick which has already cost the
taxpayer
140 million pounds and nobody's been
removed and now we know from the court
judgment this morning that the
government didn't even do the basics to
make sure that it was fit for purpose a
sentiment shared by some in scampson
where this old RAF base will become a
temporary stop for those seeking Asylum
the fact that it's been ruled as illegal
that should have been looked into before
they even started spending money sort of
trying to implement that plan the whole
thing has been immensely stressful for
the majority of people and one of the
biggest stresses and I cannot emphasize
this enough on the biggest stresses is
the lack of Engagement from the home
office we have had nothing the Home
Secretary says it's her dream to see
Asylum Seekers deported to Rwanda but to
its opponents the policy is a nightmare
they will do anything to prevent for now
the battle goes on with high stakes on
all sides Liz Bates scan news
Westminster